Reggie Miller kind enough to join us reg
good morning let me start with a couple
of questions that we've been asking do
the Raptors deserve an asterisk for this
championship absolutely not are you
kidding me
they earned that not their fault Katy
was ours not their fault clay went down
at the end of the third absent no that
was earned
championship they were the better team
they were the more consistent team and
if you look throughout this series the
players that stepped up for them other
than Kawhi Leonard Fred vanvleet Kyle
Lowery Pascal siakam who really came
into his own and was a superstar
starting from Game one in that
career-high what 32 points on 14 of 17
shooter they had the better complement
of players the superstars don't get me
wrong on Golden State but in terms of a
complete team was the Toronto Raptors
absolutely zero asterisks in my opinion
they earn this championship is the
Warriors run over yes I know everyone is
saying no but here's why I say yes now
when you say the run over meaning will
they get to another NBA Finals I say no
because you have KD we don't even know
if Katie is going to be in a Golden
State warrior uniform next season he's
going to be out for a year you've got
klay Thompson with the ACL injury going
to be out at least a year they're saying
9 to 10 months and you don't know if
he's gonna be in a Golden State warrior
uniform who comes in to be those guys if
they're not going to be there let's say
both of them do resign they're both out
a year so next year is out of the
equation are they gonna come back the
same players katie is what 32 I believe
he's gonna be coming off 31 opening
night so he'll probably be 32 by the
time you comment time he plays again in
a warrior's uniform he'll be 32
if he's in his uniform if he's in a
warrior's uniform coming back from a
ruptured Achilles clay Thompson
I believe it's 30 right I believe coming
back from an ACL injury not now
technology and science has changed which
is great that's on the side of the
players but let's face it are they going
to be the same players is Kenny going to
be the same player after that injury is
he going to be as dominant after they
say that's what is the run over getting
to the NBA Finals I have to say and on
top of that Steph Curry is going to be
two years older by the time these guys
join them again so yeah can they get
pieces possibly I just I I don't think
well will they go form playoffs yes but
to say that they're going to be winning
championships and back in the NBA Finals
anytime soon certainly that's not next
season because you have to your main
players are going to be out of the
equation more important for this run for
the Golden State Warriors Steve Kerr
Steph Curry
well 1a 1b
look Steve did and his staff did a
wonderful job and it's hard to feel
sorry for guys that have worn three out
of four championships right right so
it's hard for me to feel sorry for you
but the injuries
obviously we're mounting and let's not
forget come on Looney with the separated
collarbone wasn't even supposed to play
the rest of the series and gutted it out
DeMarcus Cousins look how long and look
what he's look like coming back from an
ACL or excuse me from an Achilles injury
okay
look how erratic his play he played well
in a couple games and other games was mi
a so that's what if you're asking about
the run being over I mean there's case
in point of a guy coming back from an
Achilles injury and how long it takes to
get back to form so Steve Kerr did a
great job of P smelliness getting them
all the way to the NBA Finals for them
to
to do what they did against Portland
without Katie and to find a way it was
just remarkable for them to win versus
James Harden and the Rockets after Katie
went down remarkable they just ran into
a better team they really did and here's
what shows you the margin of error is so
small in the NBA and you and I talked
about this we were calling that
Milwaukee Bucks Toronto Raptors series
Milwaukee went up to nothing and it was
look like it was going to be a cakewalk
for the Bucks
Milwaukee blew their chance in Game
three in that double overtime they had
that game in the bag and they ended up
losing that game and that gave Toronto
confidence they blew him out in Game
four even a series at 2-2 and went on to
win in six and if you're if you're
Giannis antetokounmpo Mike Budenholzer
and you're sitting back in your looking
at Kauai Raptor Fred vanvleet and those
collection of players holding up that
trophy you're saying to yourself that
could have been us because they look so
dominant in those first two games versus
Toronto you're thinking this is a five
game this could be a five game where the
series is over and Toronto they found a
way they won Game three in double
overtime and a light bulb went off
that's the margin of error because this
very well could have been the Milwaukee
Bucks championship yeah what will and
what should why do the king of the north
in my opinion should resign with the
Raptors everything the infrastructure is
in place now mind you I say this if
Raptors brass Masai Ujiri who needs to
give who needs to get all the credit a
lot of this for the success you fire the
defending coach of the year and you
bring in Nick nurse who was an assistant
one seat over and win a championship
used
you send one of your most beloved
players in demar derozan
and get back Kawhi Leonard and you win a
championship if I'm the King in the
north
and I'm Kauai Irie signed with Toronto
what will he do I think he he marches to
the beat of his own drum
I think he pulls a kareem abdul-jabbar
in Milwaukee Bucks saying okay guys I
got you a championship
thank you I want to go to LA I think he
I think he's gone but I loved it because
the grass will not always be greener but
I could see him in a clipper uniform I
really can because the infantry the
infrastructure and that setup is very
much like the setup in Toronto you got a
collection of role players that are good
not great and young all do their jobs
and young and they will do their jobs
surrounded by a superstar in kalila nerd
and I think he's hey I delivered a
championship to you got and on my way
back when I collect my ring the standing
ovation there should be a statue out
front of in Jurassic Park of quite
Leonard
I just statue already I just saw this
the Action Network has odds of who is
the team to beat for the NBA
championship next year you want to take
a guess I'm sure they're probably gonna
have Golden State Warriors on there nope
I think you'll be shocked Toronto
Raptors New Philadelphia 76ers nope we
may be here for a little while reg
Lakers yep the Lakers and you put the
Lakers on it I don't know the Lakers
installed is the favorites to win the
title at plus 450 behind the Lakers
future odds are the Clippers and the
Milwaukee Bucks
I'll tell you what Theodore it actually
does make a little bit of sense because
of the turmoil now that you see was
Golden State in the injuries and not
knowing where clay and Katie are going
and how long if and when they do come
back but if you don't get Anthony Davis
on the Lakers then you don't if you
don't that's why I think they know
something that we don't know and we know
that there's been conversations with
David Griffin's the new general manager
president of the pelicans along with the
Knicks the Celtics and the Lakers right
so negotiations have begun so they must
know something that we don't know but if
you don't land Anthony Davis yeah I
don't know how you could put those odds
up there if you're going by the current
team with LeBron and what we saw last
season you've got to be kidding me
well you're looking at this and you're
looking at a future bad you obviously
looking at Anthony Davis joining LeBron
the question is what are you giving up
and can you get another free agent to
come to town because if you said you can
keep Kuzma which I don't think will
happen and you have Anthony Davis you
have Jimmy Butler and you have LeBron
that's I like it yeah it's probably the
team to beat in the West yeah you know a
healthy Portland team Denver a you know
with another year experience we don't
know what Golden State's gonna have
Houston's in a state of flux here so you
know it might be the Lakers if that that
were the case but that's you still got
to get em hey David it makes sense if
the domino of Anthony Davis is coming to
the Lakers then I can see why they're
the favorites but if they don't land
Anthony Davis you can't put them in that
conversation talking to Reggie Miller
the hall-of-famer from Turner Sports I
also you know we'd love to talk legacies
here now Kawhi has won his second title
and the MVP now the second time we look
at Kawhi differently I think like a
quarterback who has multiple Super Bowls
you end up looking at them differently I
don't know if we're Kawhi fit Kai's name
never comes up during the regular season
ever because he doesn't turn in any of
those games where you go oh my god you
see what quiet
when's the last time you heard somebody
say during a regular season how did you
see what quad did never
but in the postseason he has this an
innate ability to do some very
impressive things he did it in San
Antonio he did it here this time he did
it with his own team and this load
management stuff here he only played he
only played a lot more superstars taking
nights off to be more fresh come playoff
times because he played 60 games he
missed he played 60 games this year but
played the most minutes in the
postseason yeah Wow but maybe we're
looking at this reg where the
Commissioner goes you know what let's do
70 games here you know let let me meet
you halfway here nothing drastic but
let's go 70 again I wonder as we move
forward with this load management term
how that how that affects the
commissioner and the owners is they move
forward as well because now you're
taking money I know Auggie's are the
owners and I don't know if they're gonna
let me go that way but yeah I will say
this about Kauai
that's the casual fan saying those
comments which you just said hey I can't
remember that game by cleaner you asked
any real baller college or especially
professional about Kawhi Leonard and
they will tell you that he is the truth
at both ends of the floor see the best
player in basketball you're not the best
player in basketball but he's the best
two-way player in basketball not the
best player in basketball but he's the
best two-way player get it done at both
ends of the floor
okay but as the best two-way player
where does he rank as the best player
top five you know it's sort of that
feeling there but I also wonder do we
look at Kauai differently as one of the
Great's of all time because of what he
just did with this win in Toronto yes
look you and I talked on Monday and I
said hypothetical to Fritzi about I
think the retiree is jersey in San
Antonio and in Toronto no we know in
Toronto his jersey will be retired the
question is will they
harbor any ill will feelings of how he
left there and I think he kind of
addressed that last night saying that
people thought he was faking an injury
and then he didn't want to play for
Popovich I don't think that was case
this dude he he just he goes by his own
his own feelings he just wasn't feeling
it in San Antonio and he helped deliver
them another Championships and people
tend to forget that as well as he was
Finals MVP going against a seasoned
LeBron James and Dwyane Wade and Miami
Heat team right yeah he was a young
Kauai and got Finals MVP this time
around a collection of role players I'm
not even quite sure was there a top 30
player on Toronto's team that just won
the champion siddur Kyle Lowry a top 30
Pascal siakam top 30 in the 930 player
in Italy no and you win a championship
yeah okay at least when he was with San
Antonio not that Tim Duncan was the top
30 at the time but you get Tony Parker
Manu Ginobili I mean you had guys that
understood how to win championship he
found he took a team with a bunch of
great role players and wanted
championship we have to look at him
differently we have to look at those two
Finals MVP yes he right now he is one of
the all-time great I know you got to get
the kids off to school and got to be
father of the year but thanks for
joining us on short notice reg I
appreciate it or you are the best thank
you guys I love you
that's a Reggie Miller for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]